hello everyone welcome to the webinar
today to learn about how can you use
stable cell lines
for your drug discovery project my name
is vivienne zhang i'm the product
manager of cell biology at janscript
in the webinar today i'll go through the
contents here with you
first i'll introduce to you about our
product history
and then i'll introduce to you the
workflow of how we generate stable cell
lines at janscript
and then i'll introduce to you our
portfolio
and then point out to the product
highlights at the last we'll go through
some case studies
founded in 2002 in headquarters in new
jersey usa
janskrip is now a leading company in
biotech
providing a variety of products and
services in the field of molecular
biology
proteins peptides antibodies in cellular
analysis
in 2009 we started to provide stable
cell lines for gpcr functional assay
seven years later in 2016 we extended
our portfolio
to also provide provide immune
checkpoints stable cell lines for
binding assays
as well as for functional assays one
year later
we further extended our portfolio to
also provide
the fc receptors stable cell lines for
antibody binding
last year in 2020 right after the coe19
pandemic
we have also developed related cell
lines over expressing
ace2 or sars cov2 spy protein
for investigation of the virus binding
so far we have already 10 more than 10
years of experience
in generating stable cell lines for drug
discovery
and we have successfully provided
more than 200 products covering cost
targets
in drug discovery
first of all let me introduce to you the
workflow of how we generate stable cell
lines at transcript
we start with constructing the plasmid
including both the target gene as well
as the selective gene
the plasma with the targeted gene will
be selected by the antibiotic selection
and only the target expression plasma
will be used for transfection
and from here a cell pool is generated
with heterogeneous
expression of the target gene
then we perform the dilution cloning to
get a single chrome stable cell line
and then each chrome is further expanded
in cell culture
into the one with the best performances
selected as our product
the product loan is embedded in our
inventory
further expanded in harvest and the
portion
is used for qa before the cell line
product becomes deliverables
the first question in rick about
recombine stable cell line generation
is which whole cell to choose we offer
our cell lines in various
of whole cells including cho k1 hgk 293
ht1080 and jerkid
the wholesale of each cell line product
is chosen for the best performance of
the target gene expression
and we offer as many options as possible
2k1 is the most popular whole cell used
in recombined
cell line for drug discovery it is an
epsilon cell line derived from the ovary
of chinese headmaster
the choking one cell will use that
transcript for stable cell line
generation
as a dhfr sufficient strain
these cells are easy to culture they are
tightly adherent
to the vessel and
cause the very low to grow with simple
medium
another option we offer here is hkhek
293
this cells are derived from human
embryonic cleaning cells
they are widely used due to their
reliable growth
as well as the propensity of
transfection
the cells are compatible for different
platforms especially
human disease target
a feature of the cells is that they are
easy to detach
so most mostly they are grow in
suspension cell culture
hc1080 is another option we provide
that they are delivered from the human
fibro sarcoma biopsy
the cell is a suitable model for nf
capability signaling pathway which is
necessary for immune responses
therefore we chose this cell line for
generating our email checkpoint reporter
cell lines
jerked is also our option
this cell is a cell line of human t
cells
therefore they're the perfect model for
in virtual assets to mimic the real
immune responses
talking about the expression of target
genes there are several efforts we have
done to ensure the best performance
first of all there is no tag for the
expressed target gene in our stable cell
lines
recent research has found that using the
label may cause artifacts in drug
discovery results
due to label interference
therefore the non-tech technology allows
for label-free investigation
and higher accuracy in addition
codon optimization is also performed in
our stable cell line when necessary to
increase gene
expression level in certain whole cell
lines this is due to the nature of
different wholesale lines
it can be challenging for some genes to
achieve high expression level
in certain whole cell line cooldown
optimization can solve this problem
without altering the
amino acid sequence of the target gene
to select the plasmid with target gene
expression
antibiotic selection system was applied
when constructing the plasmid both the
target gene
as well as the antibiotic resistant gene
was constructed to be driven by the same
promoter
a plasmid expressing the target gene can
then be selected by the expression
of the antibiotics a variety of
antibiotic resistant
selectable markers are used in different
products
including hypromissing b resist string
pure missing resistance zero zinc
resistance as well as
genetic synthesis gene
a two-step screening method is applied
for choosing the prodigal adjunct script
the first step is a single clone
screening
as you can see in the diagram below due
to the different transduction level and
the gene
insertion site in the chromosomes the
transducer cells generated from the
target gene expression plasmid
are actually polyclonal and present as a
heterogeneous mixture
different cell clones as shown in the
yellow and green may have different
expansion rate
therefore in the sale pool after a few
passages
you will start to see the expression
level of the
targeting start to shift due to the
outgrowth
of one clone versus another chrome
only when you have a single chrome
stable cell line you can have
the expression level stable after
passages
dilution cloning technology is applied
to generate single chrome
in this procedure the polyclonal cell
pool
after transaction is diluted to certain
concentration
before plating to a 1986 well plate
so each well contains no more than one
cell
from there a single clone cell line will
be obtained
in individual well after several days of
expansion
and then all the single clones are
further screened
to choose the product clone based on the
performance
highly producing clones are actually
rare due to the reason that
active regions supporting hygiene
expression in the chromosome
is actually rare and also
in the case of immune checkpoint stable
cell lines
some immune checkpoint proteins can
actually induce
apoptosis therefore
it is very necessary to screen for the
clone with the best performance as a
product clone
the screening method we use includes
both the facts assays
to check the expression as well as
functional assays
so when do you need to use a stable cell
lines
to answer this question we need to take
a look into the procedure of drug
discovery as shown in the diagram
here as you can see it is a very long
procedure
involving many steps the whole procedure
can be broken down into three major
stages
show in the blue at the drug discovery
stage including
target discovery validation asset
development
screening for hits leads identification
and
optimization after that
at the drug development stage which also
includes
filing of the investigational new drug
application
or called ind after that
if you get good results from the
clinical trial you can then move on to
new drug application
as well as the drug commercialization
into the in the drug discovery stage
show in the blue
after a target for a certain disease is
validated
and the related assets are developed you
start to screen a whole list of drug
candidates to identify a few ones
with good binding affinity which are
called hits
for this procedure overexpressing cell
lines are needed
then the identified kit hits will be
carried over to the next step for lead
identification
which are the one or a couple drug
candidates that can
actually active or inhibit the drug
target and this is where the reporter
cell lines come into place
next let me introduce to you the stable
cell line products that we have
at genscript that can facilitate your
research
including gpcr stable cell lines immune
checkpoint stable cell lines
fc receptor stable cell lines as well as
covalent 19 related cell lines
first let's talk about gpcr stable cell
lines
gpcr is also called seven pass
transmembrane domain receptors
or g-protein-linked receptors
there are a large group of cell surface
receptors that can detect the molecule
outside of the cell
and activate cellular responses
the ligand that binds in active various
receptors
include light sensitive compounds odors
pheromones hormones and
neurotransmitters
and vary in size from small molecule to
peptide
to large proteins
when a ligand binds to the gpcr it
causes a conformational change in the
gpcr
which allow it to act as a grinding
nucleotide
exchange factor the gpcr
can then activate an associate g protein
by exchanging the gdp bind to the g
protein for gtp the g proteins
alpha u subunit together with the bound
gtp
can then dissociate from the beta and
gamma
subunits to further affect intracellular
signal proteins
or target functional proteins directly
depending on the
alpha subunit type
gpcrs are involved in many diseases
including mental metabolic immunological
for example viral infection
cardiovascular inflammatory census
disorder
as well as cancer as you can see they
are very important drug
targets 34 percent of all fda
approved drugs actually target 108
members of this family 66 potential
normal gpcr targets
under investigation in clinical trials
and there are still 224
non-olfactory gps that have not yet been
explored in clinical trials
they and they still have broad untapped
therapeutical potential
at jamscript we offer more than 150
stable cell lines with targeted gpcr
overexpression
this covers 75 of all the potential
clinical targets
all the gpcr expressed in our stable
cell lines are human
proteins and we offer a variety of whole
cells
including choker1 hgk293 as well as
hek-293t
the gpc are stable cell lines we offer
at james grip are for functional assets
in gpcr drug lift identification
all the cell lines are fully validated
in multiple asset platforms
including calcium flex assay or fr
etsa or the chemical illumination assay
as you can see here i'm showing you some
example data from our products
in the left panel is a calcium flex
assay
in the human recombined oxytocin resets
receptor stable cell line
with increased dose of oxytocin you can
see
increase the level of the relative
fluorescent unit change
in the red panel is the representative
data from the
of the camp accumulation in the 2k1
gal15
glp-1r stable cell line
as you can see with the increased level
of glp
1 you see decrease the level of the
ratio of 665 versus 620. the next
product line i want to introduce to you
is the immune checkpoint stable cell
lines
email checkpoints are regulators of the
immune system
these pathways are crucial for the
self-tolerance
which can prevent the immune system from
attacking cells
indiscriminately however some cancers
can protect themselves from attacking
by stimulating immune checkpoint targets
cancer cells often have tumor antigens
on their
surface that can be detected by
antibodies
cancer immunotherapy is artificial
stimulation of the immune system to
treat cancer
improving on the immune system's natural
natural ability to fight the disease
the nobel prize in physiology or
medicine in 2018 was
actually awarded jointly to james p
ellison as well as takusu hong jong
for their discovery of the cancer
therapy by inhibition of the nectar
immune
regulation as you can see on the
image on the right side there are
activating receptors
including ccd28 ox40
gitr cd137 cd27
and the hvem to activate the t
cells there are also inhibitory
receptors expressing
on the t cells including ctla
4 pd1 team 3 btla
vista intellect 3.
to dark to target the activating
receptors or the inhib or the inhibitory
receptors
agnes the antibodies or the blocking
antibodies can be
developed we offer more than 50 stable
cell lines
with overexpression of different immune
checkpoints
for binding assays the species of a
protein that we express
including human mouse or monkey we offer
a variety of host cells
including token1 or hek293
the cell lines are for binding assets of
overexpressed
protein or can be used as immunogen
the high protein expression in the
stable cell lines
are validated by facts assays as you can
see here i'm showing you a example of
the fact csa analysis
of the pdl1 expression in our token1pdl1
cell
show in the blue is the expression of
the pdl1
in the stable cell line
show in the red you can see that there's
little expression of the pdl1
in the control cell line which is just
the 2k1
we also have seven reporter cell lines
for uh of immune checkpoints for
functional assays
they are all human immune checkpoint
proteins
uh and we offer whole cells include
ht1080
jericho or troll k1 these cells are for
functional assays
with a reporter expression the assay
results
are either endogenous l8 or l2
on the right you can see the reporter
il8
production assay in the ht-1080
ox-40 cell line in this case
the lh is the asset readout when the
cell line
over express ox40 is dosed
with different levels of the antibodies
for the ox40
you can see increased expression of the
l8 that is released in the into the cell
culture medium
indicating the activation of the ox-40
receptor
the next category i want to introduce to
you is the fc receptor stable cell lines
as we all know pathogens that invaded
into human body
can be recognized by antibody through
the
fab region the fc region of the antibody
can be recognized and bind by a fc
receptor
different fc receptors are expressed on
the surface of different type of immune
cells
therefore the recognization and binding
of different fc receptors to the fc
region
can recruit different type of immune
cells
and therefore activates the immune
response
to kill the pathogen in human body there
are several different type of fc
receptors
expressed on different type of immune
cells this include
fc receptor 1 receptor 2
a 2b 2c 3a
3b and neonatal
as you can see their expression patterns
are all different in variety of
different immune sites
and they can recruit the different type
of immune cells
to the pathogen and activate immune
response
the fc receptor affinity analysis
of antibody drug provides information on
which type of the immune cells are
involved
in the immune responses triggered by the
drug candidate
at jam script we provide eight most
popular fc receptor members in our
stable cell lines
including polymorphic versions all the
expressed fc receptors
are human proteins
they are all expressed in the whole cell
of the troche 1
and their great tools to study the
antibody binding
affinity and half time test
the last category i want to introduce to
you is a covet related stable cell lines
in last year we officed the global
threat
of kobe 19. so far it has been more than
100 million
infections and more than 2 million
deaths globally
and all these numbers are still rising
rapidly
cell entry of the coronal virus depends
on the spike protein binding to a
cellular
receptor and priming biocellular
proteins
recent studies demonstrate that the
angiotensin
converting enzyme to or called ace2
serves as a cell surface receptor to
bind s-protein
in the source code 2 and facilitate its
entry of those coronavirus into the cell
has therefore been proposed as the
potential therapeutic target
for kobe 19.
at james grips we have developed stable
cell lines with high expression of human
ace2
and two options of whole cells hdk293 or
trokey1
as powerful cell line tools for drug
discovery
to treat covalent 19. both cell lines
are validated
by the ac2 expression by expanding to
the s-protein rbd
domain as you can see in the facts essay
here the hgk-2983
ac e2 cell line was split into two
groups
one group was stained with the srbd
protein with a histag
and then followed by the anti-haze
fixing
another group was now stained by the
srbd
his and only stained by the anti-his
fixing
and then the level of the hixi was
detected by the flow cytometry
as yet you can see a significant
um difference was seen between the two
groups
indicating the pipe binding
of the srbd domain to the ace2 protein
on the cell surface
there are many applications of this ace2
cell lines
one of the application is screening for
the anti-ace2 antibody
the representative data i'm showing you
here is a binding assay of the s-protein
rbd
to the ace2 cells on the cell surface
as you can see with increased level of
the srbd
treated with the cell increase the level
of the
fluorescent intensity can be detected
on the cell surface by flow cytometry
another application of the cell line is
to screen for the rbd
binding inhibitors
here i'm showing you an example data
of the neutralization assay of srbd
protein by ace2 protein
the hgk293ace2 cell line
was treated with one microgram per ml
srbd in the cell culture and
ace2 protein at different concentration
and then the neutralization of the rbd
was calculated by the amount of the rbd
bind to the hdk cells by
fax assay as you can see with increase
the level of the ace2
added into the cell culture increased
the level of neutralization
can can be observed in addition
we have also developed this source code
two spike protein stable cell lines
for the investigation of covan 19.
we also offer two types of whole cells
hgk 293
and show k1 all the cell lines
are validated for the source code tools
by protein expression
by the human ace2 binding
and the cell line can be used as the
individual binding assay
we're using as immunogen here i'm
showing you a representative data
of the flow cytometry analysis of the
spike protein expression
on the trochae1 spike cells we're
binding with ace2 protein
as you can see in the red the choca
1 stars cove 2 spike
protein cell line was detected
with high level of ace 2 binding
compared to the control cell line which
is just the 2k one
the next question is why do you choose
stable cell lines from genscript for
your drug discovery project
our stable cell line products are great
cellular tools for drug discovery
and are advanced compared to other
products by the three key features here
they're stable in passages they provide
high signal versus background ratio and
also
they're ready to use first of all i want
to talk about the stability
when you use cell lines in your drug
discovery project
i encourage you to think about your data
reproducibility
this can only be guaranteed by highly
stable cell line
therefore all of our stable cell lines
are tested for
their stability for more than 15
passages
here i'm showing you two example data in
the left
is the stability test of the troke one
mt1
15 cell line the intracellular calcium
mobilization
was tested in this cell line for more
than 15 passages
on the right side is a stability test of
the ht10a
ox40 reporter cell line
in this cell line the ox-40 ligand was
added
to the cell culture and the expression
secretion of the l8 was detected in the
still pregnant
the secretion of the reporter il8 was
detected
for 20 passages and still shown to be
stable
the next critical feature you need to
consider when choose stable cell line
for drug discovery is how good is the
signal versus background ratio
in order to get significant and
interpretable data
it is obvious that you need your
cellular analysis to
to deliver high signal and background
noise as low as possible
one way to examine the s versus b
ratio is to compare the signal from the
particular cell line of interest
to its control cell line as you can see
in the example i present to you here
flow cytometry analysis of the target
gene
pd1 expression in the pd1 stable cell
line compared to its control
from either jain script or the
competitor
in the left panel you can see the
expression level of the pd1
as shown in the blue is significantly
higher
than in its control cell which is just a
12k one
however on in the right panel you can
see
the signal from the target expression
cell line
is actually overlapping in the histogram
compared to its control cell line
indicating
the cell line is probably not a single
clone
and it's not delivering the high signal
back versus background ratio
this could be a very serious issue when
you
use a cell line for your drug discovery
research
the next product feature we offer from
our stable cell line
which will be very valuable to you is
that they
are ready to use as you may know
cell line generation is a very time
consuming work
but drug discovery is very competitive
especially time
wise as you can see in the timeline of
the cell line development
in the diagram here i'm showing you the
number of weeks for each step
in week one you need to do your analysis
and verification of the dna
after that takes about a couple weeks
for the construction of the vectors
starting in week five which is your
second month
you can do transfection and selection of
the initial stable producing poles
and then it will be another couple weeks
for dilution cloning
only starting in the third month which
is week
9 to week 12 you can do expansion after
that you still need to do evaluation and
choose the top clones to get the result
you still need to do some qa
and also harvest yourselves where it
takes another couple weeks
and after that you can get to the final
deliverables
the whole procedure takes about 20 weeks
which is 5 months
of your valuable time so why do you
waste your time
speed up your drug discovery by taking
advantage of the ready-to-use cell line
products
and last i want to share with you a case
study of the troca
oxytocin stable cell lines published by
professor with her colleagues from
university of nebraska
in mammals the non-applied oxytocin
structure is highly conserved with
solution in the eighth position
however in marmoset a non-synonymous
nucleotide substitution
in the oxytocin gene calls for the
proline
in the ace residue position
therefore in this research these two
versions of the oxytocin peptide
was studied for their affinity of
binding to the oxytocin receptor
as well as activating it by using our 2k
oxytocin stable cell line
as you can see in the top panel here
the two oxytocin ligands show similar
potencies
and efficacies in increasing
intracellular calcium concentration
in the troche oxytocins stable cell line
in the lower panel you can see the leo
8 oxytocin actually shows substantially
greater potency
compared to the prohibited oxytocin in
activating the calcium potassium channel
measured by the membrane potential
sensitivity dye
fmp blue
by now you see why the stable cell lines
from javascript
can serve as great cellular analysis
tools
in your drug discovery project we have
11 years of experience in generating
stable cell lines for drug discovery
we have successfully developed more than
200 stable cell lines
expressing various hard drug targets
all of stable cell lines are single
clone they are validated for high
expression or functionality
they are stable for passages and present
high signal versus background ratio
and also they are ready to use this cell
lines
can speed up your project enable highly
reproducible data
you can find more information of the
stable cell line products
by visiting our website and go to the
kellogg product section
if you have any question regarding the
product
just go to the document tabs and open
the faqs
make sure you click on the catalog
products section
and you will be able to find your
question there
thank you all for joining the webinar
today i hope our products serve you well
in your drug discovery research
and please don't hesitate to contact
transcript if you have any questions